is the weekend calling out Exodus Selena
Gomez and Bella Hadid in his new album
we investigated well friends it appears
it's eight not so happy Friday I'm
afraid at least it feels that way for
the weekend who is bearing his broken
heart on surprise EP my dear melancholy
out in the perfect time for spring the
weekend dropped his sick song EP last
night just in time for his Coachella
headlining set but it's the salty lyrics
that have many fans speculating if the
new music is about ex Selena Gomez well
listen detective director was on the
case I did give it a listen myself and
the weekend wastes no time
the first song call out my name really
goes for it take a look
[Music]
[Music]
falling for you was my mistake
oof the weekend is sounding like a
Monday it's hard not to connect the line
about helping Selena out of a broken
place with her ongoing health and mental
health struggles or a roller coaster
romance with Justin Bieber
in fact the weekend seems to call her
out for running back so swiftly to the
Biebs
with this lyric guess
[Music]
is the weekend Drake now I mean can you
blame this tortured soul many are
suggesting that line I almost cut a
piece of myself for your life could it
be a direct reference to Selena's kidney
transplant which happened just a few
months before they broke up now the rest
of the EP is a journey the weekend seems
about finding closure and one way to do
that diss your ex
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in wasted times not only is there that
possible Selina disk but is he singing
this to his other famous ex Bella Hadid
well there's also one very specific
lyric that has us thinking that's the
case let me remind you guys that Bella
is not only a supermodel she used to
ride horses competitively too so does
the weekend regret moving on from Bella
with Selena Gomez wall Bella and the
weekend split near the end of 2016
before he started JD Selena then there
were rumors the weekend reunited Bella
after the Selena break up while Selena
was rumored to be back together with
Bieber you guys still with me okay cool
so what do you guys make of the
weekend's new stuff is he ripping a page
out of Taylor Swift's diary and pouring
out his heart about his failed
relationships let me know in the comment
section all right the weekend is not the
only artist dropping some new tunes
today it is time for new music Friday
Tyler the Creator dropped his latest
song okra and the visual for the new
track has already racked up over 2
million views and the best part it gives
a special shout-out to our boy call me
by your name star Timothy Shalem a
tilton elementary at me skin glow so
holographic red ones look like a
thematic spin there
like sexy driver and handmade is that
thing with times but I wrote them I can
feel said behind me and they got the can
I like your back Neriah yeah we straight
sit if you like the situation we'll go
grab the onion and he makes my Campbell
I shall obey actually reacted to Tyler's
call out by retweeting this it's him
falling out of a chair but listen I
almost fell out of mine when I heard Sam
Smith's revamp of his song break this
time the song has been blessed by rapper
logic anybody anybody
[Music]
isn't that beautiful logic tweeted this
is the most important feature he's ever
done writing from the perspective of
someone who feels unwanted and
unaccepted and finally my favorite band
churches has been serving snacks from
their upcoming album and the electro pop
group's latest offering is just as
delicious this is never say die
[Music]
[Music]
hello you guys have it my new music
Friday pics time to go enjoy the weekend
make get it like the guy outside them up
in the game this show I didn't mean to
do that no pun intended but anyways make
sure you guys are subscribed to eat
tease YouTube channel you've got a lot
of fun interviews and Coachella PBS
coming your way and the next couple
weeks so stay tuned I'll see you on
Monday
clearly I deserve this weekend okay I
did it again
[Music]